are you ready jazz is definitely very
intellectual in order to do it you
really have to dive into the harmony and
figure out what's going on and I think
there's a part of all of us that really
likes analyzing things jazz it's always
been a huge part of my life and before I
came to MIT I thought I was giving it up
and that I was just gonna devote my life
to science and I was shocked when I came
here that was actually very much the
opposite
if ever there was a particular mentor
that really left great impression on me
it was her pomeroy I would study with
him in the daytime and then play with
him on the bandstand at night I mean
that was as good as it could be we're
not just playing standards were playing
new innovative music and breaking new
ground there was a lot of pressure here
and I think that the people who are
really interested in music we're using
that as their main outlet
I know it's going to be a great evening
I hope you enjoy the peace which I
haven't written yet and i will write
there's nothing to stop MIT from being a
leader in the jazz field for another 50
years
you